[Music]
welcome to Tech news briefing it's
Monday May 22nd I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
video game enthusiasts are scouring
social media platforms looking not for
clues for how to beat the most popular
games but in hopes of finding classified
U.S government documents what they're
after is a cache of sensitive military
information that the justice department
alleges Jack to Shara a U.S Air National
Guardsman posted on Discord Tashara
hasn't entered a plea with me to discuss
how Gamers became so involved in this
Saga is our national security reporter
Jessica Donati Jessica can you tell us
how this all started so it all started
when top secret U.S documents some that
were crudely doctored began appearing on
Russian telegram accounts the source of
these apparently top secret documents
was eventually traced back to Discord
which is an app that's popular with kids
that play video games and kids that do
their homework together what happened
was a 21 year old Airmen in the 102nd
intelligence wing of the Massachusetts
Air National Guard had been sharing
highly classified information that he
had obtained from his job with a small
group of friends in a private Discord
group
this happened for months at some point
one of those online friends took these
documents got into an argument with
somebody on another more public server
and shared them leading to these
documents being reposted and ending up
on telegram which was monitored by media
and eventually picked up by the world's
attention Okay how did Gamers get so
involved in all of this this seems like
something that would involve spies more
likely so for some teenagers this was a
really exciting chance to see real-life
top secret documents that they would
normally only see in movies and so some
of these kids were already in the groups
where these top secret documents had
been shared and many of them took it
upon themselves to start searching for
these documents to see how many they
could collect you mentioned for those of
us who are not as familiar with Discord
it's very popular with teenagers can you
just remind us how the platform works
and how it became so popular with young
people and with Gamers Discord is a San
francisco-based app that started in 2015
and it became popular with the rise of
video games like fortnite and eventually
it has become popular for other users as
I mentioned people doing their homework
together or watching movies together one
of the things about Discord that is
really popular with teenagers is that it
doesn't monitor private Communications
it doesn't collect private user data and
it doesn't use these for ads the problem
with it though is the fact that there is
little monitoring means that it can be
used for things that are potentially
illegal like sharing of classified
documents and other activities other
specific skills that Gamers would have
that would make them well suited for
this you know scouring of the platform
to find documents I mean one of the
things that Gamers have is a familiarity
with Discord and perhaps membership in
many of these groups where these
documents were shared and so for
teenagers who are very very comfortable
navigating the app who have knowledge
perhaps of coding are able to dig out
this information that was shared in
different places you chatted with some
of the people who are involved in
looking for these documents how did they
describe the experience I started out to
see if I could also find classified
documents on the app and what I
immediately discovered was that there
were many teenagers that were also
trying to do the same thing and talking
to a number of them I asked them why are
you so interested in these documents and
there was a wide range of reasons and
one of them being that they could show
off in front of their school friends and
say look I've got secret classified
documents but there were other reasons
for example some teenagers did didn't
trust the median so they wanted to see
the documents for themselves some of
them hadn't trusted reporting about the
war or the way that Ukraine or Russia
was characterized by the media and many
of the documents contained information
about the war so they wanted to see for
themselves something more authentic and
raw the other thing to know is that
users on Discord come from all around
the world so many of them were not
American teenagers but teenagers in
Europe or in Asia who spoke English and
they were not afraid of being prosecuted
by the US government or having you know
the FBI show up at their door so for
them it was a challenge I didn't have
any restrictions is
and something these teens could face
the first that we whisper to because
they did not have any legal obligation
to protect that information it is very
unlikely that they would be prosecuted
for sharing it alright that was wsj
National Security reporter Jessica
Donati and that's it for today's Tech
news briefing for more Tech stories head
over to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
foreign